Lebanese are becoming poorer there
doesn't seem to be a clear way out of
the country's worst economic crisis in
decades shortages of dollars have driven
up the price of basic goods the Consumer
Protection Agency reports increases of
at least 40 percent which is how much
value Lebanon's local currency has lost
on the black market in recent months in
Heluva the milk used to cost twelve
thousand Lebanese pounds it is now 40
thousand prices are increasing but our
salaries have not increased and we are
not being paid in dollars officials say
they are working to address the
financial hardships people face even
though they have warned it will involve
unpopular measures the new government is
battling a crisis of confidence at home
and abroad
there is no reason a country this
blessed with so many gifts including
incredible human resources does not have
in 2020 a modern waste management system
24/7 electricity for everyone a single
armed force under the control of the
state and a growing economy
Lebanon's dollar reserves are drying up
which makes it hard for the state to pay
back the public debt and import basic
supplies like wheat medicine and flour
the Prime Minister Hassan tab is trying
to secure financial aid to Lebanon and
it's not easy he is accusing his
opponents of convincing Arab and Western
nations not to give any help but those
nations have repeatedly made it clear
any assistance depends on the government
showing commitment to serious reforms
and combating corruption that has been
the demand of anti-establishment
protesters who have been on the streets
for more than four months their numbers
have dwindled and the movement has lost
momentum but that can change we believe
that the anger at the current situation
economic and political situation is
still out there but I think it's
building up and there will be a moment
that comes when people will come down
again people try to bring down the
symbols of the state and overthrow the
old political class the state fought
back but as more and more Lebanese
economically drained and warnings of a
potential collapse approach reality
these walls may do little to protect
those in power
sanika dar al jazeera Beirut